bonjour pierre martinet merci d'être
avec nous ce matin pour répondre à nos
questions sur rt france quelle est la
menace terroriste en france aujourd'hui
six ans après les attentats du 13
novembre
alors il faut voir il me laisse plus
globale je dirais camunas en europe et
est toujours présente la menace
d'attaqués pilote est toujours présente
en europe ça veut pas ça veut pas ça
c'est évidemment pas arrêté depuis
depuis le 11 septembre 2001 la menace
terroriste en europe à l'occident n'a eu
de cesse de progresser
en revanche il faut il faut ajouter
cette menace
violente cette menace d'attentât cette
menace d' attaque qui peut arriver à
n'importe qui n'importe quand je veux
dire et par n'importe qui puisque
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas forcément
en préparation je n'ai pas d'éléments ça
c'est mon c'est mon avis personnel je
les pales il n'y a pas forcément de
préparation de dettes attentats de
grande ampleur comme le 13 comme le 13
novembre 2015 où ça a demandé de la
préparation d'un logistique d'armes
allemand à la fabrication d'explosifs
des déplacements saad monnaie grosse
préparation pour acura pour avoir des
attaques simultanées sur le sol français
qui n'avait jamais eu lieu depuis depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale je dirais est
en revanche aujourd'hui on a plus sur
des attentats qui peuvent être commis
par des individus seuls qu'ils adhèrent
au projet islamiste et qui peuvent
passer à l'action avec une voiture un
camion un caillou un marteau ou un
couteau ça arrive régulièrement de manas
endogène ou exogène souvent qu'est ce
que ça signifie exactement et laquelle
est la plus à surveiller
en fait c'est les deux il faut
comprendre que le projet islamiste c'est
un projet global le projet islamiste un
projet mondial donc il peut y avoir des
gens qui doit qui vont encore qu'ils
peuvent encore s'infiltrer en europe
puisque les frontières de l'europe sont
des passoires ils peuvent encore 5 500
en europe pour commettre des attentats
en revanche il y a des français
aujourd'hui de confession musulmane qui
adhèrent au projet islamiste et qui
selon eux
je rappelle que dans le projet islamiste
il y à une partie idéologique une partie
on va dire de financement et une partie
de d'action filantes et les violentes
peuvent être commises par des individus
qui adhèrent au projet
islamiste et qui selon eux
doivent commettre des actions voleurs
violents pour imposer ce projet je
rappelle que le terrorisme est un moyen
d'un projet d'imposer cette idéologie
islamiste donc les deux sont aussi
importantes je dirais que le vivier
aujourd'hui
d'islamistes en comment dirais-je en
europe est très important et je dis fais
la différence entre ceux qui adhèrent et
dans quelle région de rappelant que
kader mangane est très important
qu'elles peuvent aussi mais bah écoutez
moi je vis en angleterre depuis cinq ans
c'est très important mais là il ya moins
d'actions violentes en revanche la le
niveau de revendications religieuses est
plus importante en long par exemple en
moins de festayres mais en belgique est
aujourd'hui en france parce qu'elle a
géré actuellement je suis en france je
trouve que le que que l'impact
idéologique est très important et de
plus en plus important en france alors
mieux protéger la population face à
cette menace djihadiste il ya des moyens
qu'ont déjà été mis en place est-ce
qu'ils sont suffisants ou qu'il faudrait
faire de plus alors il y à il ya trois
aspects comme je vous le disais un petit
peu avant il ya l'aspect idéologique à
l'aspect financement et un aspect
actions violent je vais j'ai commencé
par le troisième l'élection l'accès des
actions violentes ce sont les attentats
ce sont les les attentats qui peuvent
être commis par des individus isolés par
des groupes organisés
saona raconte arriver à les déceler
parce que tous les services de
renseignement européens donc français ce
sont leurs peuples réaction adaptée à
cette femme à cette menace il ya des
délits à des agents infiltrés il ya des
sources il ya des des écoutes il ya tout
ça c'est bon on s'adapte et on peut
déjouer des attentats si l'attentât est
commis aujourd'hui on a des unités
d'intervention qui arrive à intervenir
très rapidement là il ya encore et
encore une amélioration sur les primes
aux intervenants et c'est là que je fais
souvent référence à israël qui a des
sociétés privées qui sont armés qui
protège des monuments des restaurants ou
des cinémas et qui sont capables
d'intervenir très rapidement ou les
polices la police du quotidien qui ont
une société privée ça veut dire que
l'armée la police
les gendarmes les forces de l'ordre
public en terme général ne suffisent pas
je ne dis pas qu'elles suffisent pas je
dis qu'on peut améliorer ces primes aux
intervenants en ayant une vraie
collaboration entre privée et
d'institutions comme le fait israël
comme le font d'autres pays anglo saxons
mais ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui
c'est que cette menace elle est globale
donc il faut tout tout tout là on y
reste toutes les forces de sécurité sont
importantes dans cette menace il ya
aussi le renseignement qui est très
important mais il ya aussi quand
l'attentât survient les primes aux
intervenants qui sont très importants
pour stopper
ou à lire pour stopper dans les secondes
dans les minutes l'attentât parce que
c'est comme un feu un feu de forêt si on
prendra ce conte qui dans des des sondés
le démarrage on peut le stopper c'est
exactement la même chose mais il y a un
gros travail à faire aujourd'hui et
selon moi c'est là où l'europe et
l'occident pêche c'est sur l'idéologie
on a on ose pas s'attaquer à l'idéologie
par peur de faire des amalgames de
stigmatiser on en est encore là quinze
ans après on ne touche pas à sa
typologie on a peur de nommer les cette
idéologie on a peur de criminaliser le
salafisme ou de mettre les frères
musulmans sur sur la liste des groupes
terroristes comme le trap voulait le
faire mais il n'a pas eu le temps au
courage de le faire il est aujourd'hui
important pour stopper les attentats
parce que les acomptes à ce ne sont que
des conséquences de cette idéologie on
travaille sur les oreilles sur les
conséquences mais pas sur la cause et la
cause aujourd'hui c'est l'idéologie cela
lui ce qu'il faut absolument stopper
merci pierre martinet d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
un ex agent du service action de la dgse
et vous êtes actuellement à la tête de
la société ou une corde security defence